hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and in the
next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the broadcaster and former mp anna
subray
and the political editor of the sun
harry cole thank you both so much for
joining us
looking forward to going through choices
in a moment let's see what is on the
front of some of those papers
the us president joe biden has joined
both the uk and irish prime ministers in
calling for calm
in northern ireland following a week of
violence the situation
in belfast is the main picture for the
metro but the front page is also
dedicated
to the staff at pubs restaurants and
shops in england while working
around the clock to get ready to reopen
in three days time
keep taking the astrazeneca vaccine the
plea on the front of the eye
over blood clot concerns linked to the
jab
while the times reports that the
majority of britons trust the oxford
vaccine according to a poll by the
newspaper
the telegraph says holidaymakers will
have to pay hundreds of pounds for
covert tests if they want to go abroad
but the mail says travelers will get
free test kits before they jet off on
foreign travel which could start as
early as next
month the yorkshire post leads on the
impact that the pandemic has had on
children's mental health
the ft reports that president biden's
administration
is calling for the world's biggest
companies to pay levies to national
governments
based on their sales
well as i said we are joined tonight by
anna siebri and harry cole
lots and lots for us to to get through
uh we'll start with the situation in
belfast
uh you've picked out the metro as your
first
paper i know that their their front page
the bad old days are back with the
headline glorious 12th below it
possibly a little ill advised
yes i i know the reference to which you
are making but
let's concentrate on northern ireland if
if we can
about what's actually happening at the
moment and why it's so important
um and and it has to be noted that if
you
look at which papers have actually even
got northern ireland on the front page
it's the metro it's the guardian but
there's no mention
in the times there's no mention um
in the telegraph either they don't want
to talk about it now
i think there's a there's a very clear
reason why they don't and that is
because
these disturbances are largely linked to
the dreadful brexit deal and the
consequences of brexit
and they don't want to talk about that
at all but the metro to its credit
is at least saying that this is a story
that we should be talking about and of
course there is this real fear
that we are indeed going back to the
days which i'm certainly old enough to
remember
and these dreadful outbreaks of
sectarian violence
i mean these shots which you have are
taken
where there are attacks on the police it
started
uh in the so-called unionist communities
or parts of them uh but it is not going
away and this story will
not go away however much uh people who
are keen supporters of brexit might want
it to is
this is the beginning of the breakup of
the uk in my opinion
it is also on the front of the financial
times um
london and dublin appealing for calm and
of course we know that their words
have been joined by by joe biden's as
well uh in the last
couple of hours i mean harry the message
coming from
some people in northern ireland it seems
to be the uk government didn't listen
to unionists concerns do you do you
think that that is a
a fair point for them to make i mean how
they are making it is is a different
matter isn't it
absolutely there is obviously there is
obviously been very increasingly
vocalized complaints
that the unionists are not being
listened to
they're being increasingly silent now
this isn't a justification for violence
this isn't and as every
every scientist has said on a political
level stop
this isn't the answer um however there
is a growing
feeling within the union's community
that they are being cut out they are
being sidelined they're being and that
goes back to before the brexit process
but the brexit process
has really brought that to the surface
and it's not just brexit despite the
um opponents of the of what's happened
over the last five years in this country
would love it to all be about brexit
there are other factors the trigger for
this really has been
has been the um appalling scenes we saw
an ira funeral
that saw frontline politicians uh for
their their friends in
in politics turn out despite thumbing
their nose at every covered regulation
going and then getting away scot-free
that has added to the sense within the
unionist community that they are being
ignored they're being shunned and
there's one rule for
for them and one rule for others so it
is it has come to
a boiling point on the bigger picture
about brexit
i i think you know what do what do those
people
and i'm not necessarily including anna
in this but what do those people want
who say
that this is all because of brexit are
they saying
that they that brexit should have been
stopped that the referendum should have
been overturned
and you know the will of the people
should have been ignored
because i think they need to listen to
how that what they actually mean
by when they see that because you're
seeing violence on the street here that
some people want to pin on brexit
but you would have seen similar scenes
across the country i think
had the uh had the the referendum result
being ignored as some wished
do you think that's a fair point to make
anna that that would have seen
writing on the streets of wolverhampton
over brexit in the same way
no no no the the problem is
is that we never understand the
consequences of brexit
on northern ireland and what it would
mean and whichever way you cut it
unless you had membership of the single
market in the customs union
then you were going to have to put a
border effectively um
in in in the irish sea and that is what
has happened because it was the only way
that you could deliver brexit
and that obviously is going to have
profound consequences
because effectively we are disjointing
our united kingdom and whether people
like it or not
it means that the cause for the northern
ireland
to be united as as many would call it uh
with the republic
are growing and the danger is is that if
there's a border pole
then we will get into that territory of
people wanting
to join the uh with the republic and so
the sort of conversation we need to have
is to say
what is in our countries in the united
kingdom's best interest
and i think we come back yet again and
it's an old argument i accept
because we've left the european union
it's not about rejoining it's about
getting
that single market and that customs
union which would ensure that that
situation in northern ireland
is is is effectively eradicated and
as it happens it would be very much in
the interests of the entire economy for
the united kingdom
harry um you know the northern ireland
secretary
is obviously intervening and getting
involved but do you think
that this should go higher up do you
think that you know boris johnson should
be across there should be sorting this
out
i'm not sure to be honest quite what the
prime minister going to northern ireland
tomorrow is going to do uh to to
alleviate tensions in in all honesty i
think the last
thing people want is a load of day
trippers turning up to uh to
corp um there are better ways of dealing
with that i'm i'm going to resist the
temptation because we'll be here all
night to pile in on
to anna's uh anna's argument there that
we should reopen the last five years of
um
of debates about the about the entire
uk's membership of the customs union
and the single market only to say that
you know there was a degree of
inflexibility and in transience by the
eu who
who who wanted to were perfectly willing
to use the
the situation on the island of ireland
and northern ireland itself as a bit of
a
bit of a pawn uh in the negotiations and
and that is coming home to roost um how
about it but in
in the short term i agree with anna
though that you know it isn't about re
fighting the
fighting the old battles there does need
to be a solution to this
this isn't going to go away the
unionists you know
are adamant that their place in the
union is
is being undermined by this protocol and
without
a return to that particular issue i
don't really see how this does dissipate
without
broadly a large part of the brexit deal
being fundamentally ignored
um however i do i you know i'm not sure
what boris johnson turning up would do
but i do i i do slightly agree that
you know we should be paying a bit more
attention to to this situation than we
currently are
you talked about the eu being
intransigent uh despite that lots of
people would still want to go there for
their summer holidays if they possibly
could which brings us on to the story
the telegraph and also the mail um
the daily telegraph saying talk about
the backlash over the cost of these
tests for for holidays
uh we spoke to isabel oakshaw earlier in
the week on the pay-per-view and she was
saying that she'd paid out
not not far short of a one and a half
thousand pounds for tests
for her and her children to go away it
does seem extraordinarily expensive
the telegraph says there's a backlash
over the cost of the mail is saying
that they are going to be uh possibly
free
which which is the truth it's they're
both true
is the reality of this now the big
debate about these traffic lights is in
green zone countries
um you will require a test to get on the
plane before you come back into england
now it looks like they're going to be
the free pcr tests
sorry the free lateral flow test that
the government are rolling out for
everyone to be able to have
a couple of times a week now you'll be
able to pack those in your suitcase and
before you fly back into the uk
you will be you'll be able to take a
free test now where the expense is going
to come
is the the is taking a pcr test three
days
after you've returned to the uk now this
is crucial in the eyes of the department
of health matt hancock's been pushing
this particularly of
let's not knock the the vaccine roller
over the worst thing that could happen
now
is we vaccinate everyone we get to july
and everyone's been offered their first
job and then a variant of concern comes
along that
the vaccine doesn't uh that isn't as
effective against
and sets us back to square one and we're
back to you know the virus ripping
through the community
now a pcr test would be
able to spot new variants even if it's
in a green zone country where the
prevalence of the corona virus isn't
that that high
you could still bring back a variance so
the the sort of deal that seems to be
done here
is you know the the the treasury and and
travel
depart and the transport department have
been pushing for
tourism to be given the green light for
people to be able to travel to
people able to come here crucially as
well for holidays
now the deal seems to be done that yes
you can come here but you've got to fork
out for that quite expensive pcr test
on the second day so there's no to
getting away from the fact holidays are
gonna be more expensive and
very briefly anna i mean do you think
it's enough to to have a lot of the
lateral flow tests or do you think we
really should be still
doing the pcr tests
now the pcr test is the is the better of
the of the two tests
but i think the reality is is that there
aren't going to be that many countries
on that green light in any event
um and yeah i think that they're
probably going to be some
eu countries um and that they might
include the moldives but you know
the vast majority of people when they go
on the holidays don't go off to the
waldorf they go to
france they go to greece they go to
portugal they go to spain they go to
italy so
those are the sorts of countries which
are going to be interesting to see uh
where we are
in the summer but yeah crikey people
need a summer break
and they need often to go to the
guaranteed sunshine
actually and we shouldn't forget of
course it's not just people on holiday
but also people
visiting family as well um thank you
both very much lots more to come from
you in the second half uh including the
crime that's risen
by a fifth the government announces a
new task force to combat
dog napping stay tuned
it actually uh my experience was into
august 2019 i uh
i i was on the business trip for the
british consulate
generals in hong kong in shenzhen but
when i've been back
in hong kong physically in west carolina
which is in central
hong kong i've been instructed and
delivered back to shenzhen i've been
interrogated
for political reason i've been suspected
as
like a person to instigate the protest
back in hong kong
so i've been interrogated by the
national security police that time
but i have a very lucky uh because that
i've been released afterwards
on the estimated numbers of the home
office
it could be about 300 000
b know citizens with their independence
to come to the uk
over five years but when we see the
rates
of the applications now um actually with
far exceeds that's the
estimated numbers of the home office
which is a good thing because
it's quite attractive to hong kong
people
who wanted to flee from the tyranny so i
believe that as quite
many hong kongers they are losing hope
to achieve moxie
and dance they definitely wanted to
fight a haven
so far at this moment still that they
need to apply that online
or that's through the website for the
bno
visa and that's they need not to have
valid to be a new passport they come
here as provided they have uh
the you know stages sometimes they can
they can apply
the bno visa so far we're very
appreciative and
grateful for the uk government and
because that's the provide very
comprehensive and powerful support
package
for hong kongers to uh reset tours in
the uk
um although we haven't uh note about
more details how to apply for that fund
but
as uh founders of the hong kongers in
britain one of the uh civil society
organizations to provide the support
uh to hong kongers um i think definitely
in the future
uh will be in blue to understand that
how
we can proceed concretely but definitely
that would be a very great means
for most of the hong kongers especially
that's being all citizens
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to the safety rage
podcast for the ones who want to know
more welcome to the all-out politics
podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news listen and subscribe
for free
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now the broadcaster and
former mp anna subri and the political
editor of the sun harry cole
um and the story that we're starting
this half with is
rishi sunak and david cameron's texts
anna
the the telegraph has that on the front
uh sunak pushed cameron bank request
we've had the the release of of sunax
replies to text from david cameron under
a freedom of information
uh requests but we don't know what david
cameron said in the first place do you
think
david cameron should just really come
clean now release all the texts and get
it all out in the open
well i think it's actually more what
rishi sunang's done which is
that he has published what was on his
private mobile phone the text
bag which is well we've i've asked my
officials to have a look at it and we've
we've had a look at it and
there's nothing we can do about it and i
know how this looks but
i'm just trying to take a little step
back and think
you get a request from somebody uh and
it happens to be the former prime
minister
saying look could you have a look at the
rules relating to something which
i'm sure he was upfront about the fact
he was involved in it
um and see whether or not it might be
that they could be in some way changed
because they're not helping
uh a british business and i saw a
comment from a member of parliament that
was
well you know i've got businesses in my
patch that would like that sort of
access well actually they do have that
sort of access
because they have a member of parliament
who can make those requests
to rishi sooner or anybody else isn't
the point not
whether or not he should have sent me i
think it reflects badly on camera
yes and should therefore he
just release his text he's been very
quiet about it
well i don't i i mean he's he is a
private citizen
frankly i am very disappointed in him
because you know you
it just it looks a bit grubby doesn't it
and it's a bit you know
how many more ministers can i go begging
almost to say
guys can you help me out here please
it looks bad and it looks demeaning of a
prime minister
harry briefly your thoughts before we
move on to dot napping i think the whole
thing's a bit
a bit sad really he's sitting in his in
his um
in his shepherd's hut you know firing
off texts
as if he was still sort of relevant and
clearly they didn't get him very far
which is the
the sort of um humiliating bit of it i
think pigs will fly before we he
he comes out and releases his text
because i imagine
the treasury has spared his blushes a
bit here i bet they are excruciatingly
cringe-worthy
and would look bad um but i think the
president here is really interesting
russia sunak wouldn't be
wouldn't be offering these up before
then before all the deadlines on foi and
various things like that
if he thought he was in trouble here but
the president is fascinated now it's
brilliant for journalists
and we couldn't be happier about this
and the fact that private phones of
ministers are now
in play under foi and there's no way
we're gonna have to leave it there's
time